there's sort of like a unspoken code
it's right that we get celebrated women
rule supreme it feels really amazing you
know a lot of people be thinking like
it's supposed to be like a caddy thing
and it just feels good like when other
women show love to each other and they
don't know how much like that means to
me though like that that means that
you're you know what if one day you need
a kidney I might give you mine I think
right now especially with everything
going on in my industry it's really it's
empowering to see the voice that women
have right now it's it's crucial and
it's important women love to be sexy and
you can't tell a woman she can't be sexy
because she's a certain shape size color
you know how I feel about inclusivity is
so important to me it's such a huge part
of my brand I think it's incredible that
we acknowledge women who do kind of
stand up and go against string this
dream and and and do things outside the
box and and and not and then you can
celebrate each other I think that's
beautiful my life doesn't gravitate
towards being edgy sexy or cool I just
naturally am NOT any of those things
when I go in your head what are you
I'm imaginative I'm smart and I'm
hard-working and those things are not
necessarily prioritized in pop culture
celebrate what connects us rather than
what divides us the feminine qualities
of being a woman are about being
compassionate and loving understanding
intuitive knowing yourself and being
aware of others and how you treat them
and how they treat you despite being
born biologically male I still represent
all of the qualities of femininity
femininity that women represent
what stands out to you this year you
know I think what stands out is just the
female empowerment and not in a negative
way of like calling people I mean like
calling women together there's room for
everyone and we can love each other's
art and everybody can be successful and
we don't always have to be pitted
against each other and I feel like they
do that a lot of times with women and so
it was just a very cool thing to be part
of just to be reminded of it let's
support each other come on girl I'm not
what do you think I am from what I
understand Marvel New Year's before this
that they were going to open this movie
on International Women's Day that's
special just shows like that they're
being pointed as well as to like what
this movie means or what it can mean I
should say kind of surreal at the end of
the day we all want the same thing we
all just want to like live in a very
harmonious loving kind empowered state I
feel the most powerful when I'm with my
family I really do I think we have a lot
of strong powerful women and they all
inspire me in different ways I have
learned to do what I want to do and stay
true to who I am no matter what anyone
else wants me to do or things I want a
different world for both my kids I have
a girl and a boy and I want both of them
to grow up with different ideas of
opportunity of behavior of the options
open to them because both boys and girls
are limited by a system that expects
very very specific things from boys and
from girls
everyone's options are limited because
of this little boy with big girl dreams
there is a whole world out there I think
so often it feels so easy to feel alone
in this space and as someone who's in
the community but really there's a whole
world out there that's ready to love you
I think there is so much cruelty in the
world obviously we know this day and age
but there also is so much love and there
is so much hope and I just really want
someone to realize that there's just a
whole world out there
the sense of sisterhood and community is
really important to two women and
everywhere we deserve equality and the
time is up